foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
now that we are up under our body's
regime my bag of mangoes now cost eleven
dollars and 99 that seems like a pretty
good deal bag of mangoes mango art
mangoes
that's it eight or eleven bucks
mangoes
[Music]
all right
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified
[Applause]
don't want me to me
it's highway robbery is what you doing
mangoes
[Music]
[Music]
Trump was doing this with his personal
toilets
15 times
[Music]
[Music]
15 times
[Music]
what on Earth is going on with Trump
toilets
Trump's White House toilet
would be clogged
clogged
[Music]
with documents that Donald Trump was
flushing down the toilet
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
Obama ten times
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much elements of
bathrooms welcome everybody we are back
from well I mean it's I'm here back from
what is kind of a big statement but we
are going to hear from Joe Biden that I
can tell you for sure this will be a
speech in fellow Philadelphia
Pennsylvania Joe Biden is expected to
address the Maga movement and the threat
it presents to democracy as you can see
there is bulletproof glass that has been
placed around where the president will
be speaking a red carpet has literally
and metaphorically been laid out for Joe
Biden and this is going to be quite a
speech we have an extraordinary
situation in the United States of
America right now
where on the one hand we have an
election an election that by all
historical assessments Republicans
should do very well in and yet they are
continuing to falter more and more in
the polls that being said they likely
would still end up taking the house but
Democrats will likely keep the Senate
but legislative accomplishment after
legislative accomplishment has stacked
up for Joe Biden as it is almost I mean
as it is increasingly looking as though
the failed former president Donald Trump
is going to be indicted
for you know light Espionage and a
variety of other different alleged
crimes and so this revitalization of
Biden now has him out on the campaign
trail with Democrats running in November
as well as tonight issuing a prime time
National address which I am very much
looking forward to Joe Biden has brought
the energy lately and we will see what
happens tonight but we have so many
other things to go over so this uh
Speech coverage starting on most
networks in seven minutes in the speech
at 8 pm as far as I know right now we
have so many things to go over
and we are going to do that now you some
of you may be saying David uh like why
does that thing above your head already
say eight you just started the stream
well eight great people including our
friend Lars Baron Roth known as deeper
shades of house on Twitch uh have been
up re-upping and upping I guess we would
say their twitch Prime subscriptions I
also want to say a huge thank you to
Adam Gingrich and Jason sickmeyer who
between the two of them just gifted
three subscriptions on my website
putting us at 11. folks the coupon code
is indict we all know what it means with
Obama gate we didn't know what it meant
what the hell is Obama gate I don't know
with the coupon code indict we know
exactly what it means exactly what it
means here is a body double for Joseph R
Biden Jr
um more sweaty than Biden typically is
but okay that's it is what it is
um I also want to say thank you to S
Prez as well as lackluster nerd and gen
here for between the three of them
uh contributing 22 subscriptions 20 of
them are from Espress immediately
putting us at 33 and thanks to Badness
for the twitch Prime subscription as
well folks let's get right into the
content Rusty says David I hope
fatherhood is treating you well I
recently met an Argentinian woman that
agreed to let me cook for her what
culturally appropriate dish should I
make for her your hair advice helped
yeah sure listen I would make her some
homemade empanadas maybe uh maybe beef
and black olive empanadas and
um I don't know what else maybe milanesa
milanesa is arguably my favorite
Argentinian dish which really is an
appropriated Italian Dish I mean let's
all be completely honest here you know
I'm not looking to take credit for
things that don't belong to me that's
that's for damn sure thanks to Jeff in
Boston for gifting five subscriptions
and also because of tiger girl
um and tuj it puts us already at 41.
folks let's go through a couple
different things Jamie Foxx it turns out
does an incredible Donald Trump
impression and it's so good that I
thought that this was dubbed I thought
this was fake check check out how good
this is it's a lot of great people on
both sides they're actually great people
and Bill Sykes I know Ariel he's a great
person he couldn't vote for me at the
time but now he can vote for me once he
gets out I love Snoop great person so do
you love Death Row Records
excuse me excuse me excuse me fake news
a little different
what's your favorite Death Row Record on
Mr Trump I love them
I could still try to pin me down excuse
me excuse me fake news
[Laughter]
they tried to give me the virus
they try to give him a verse
man that is really really good stuff
like that is really really really good
um so there's Jamie Foxx uh dropping
some knowledge on all of us yeah I mean
that's funny honestly that's funnier
than anything I've seen on SNL probably
for years at this point
um okay let's continue I have other
things for you Donald Trump called into
the John Fredericks radio show this is
so damn funny what are these shows I
have no idea what is real America's
voice I like we cover clips from real
America's voice I couldn't tell you is
it a cable channel I don't I don't think
it's a YouTube channel I looked on
YouTube they don't seem what are these
shows that Donald Trump is calling into
anyway here he says everything was
Declassified which is a complete
distraction it's nothing I mean that
that's not a thing it's not I
Declassified everything isn't a thing
but that's what Trump's going with now I
mean you look at this and you look at
what they spread out on the floor by the
way the echo I mean it's just it's not
even like these are really well produced
shows that I haven't heard of what is
this were you actually like packing
these boxes and like shipping them in
your car to Mar-A-Lago like how did they
get there
so what you do is you accumulate a lot
of stuff over a term and then all of a
sudden you're leaving and stuff gets
packed up and sent right all sorts of
stuff you know mostly the boxes pictures
and newspapers and shirts and gear I
like that gear what exactly counts as
gear does anybody know what the hell
gear is
all of a sudden it's time to leave and
he has all this gear and shirts Trump
seems like the guy who you know like the
free shirt that the energy drink people
give you he would keep it as a
memorabilia of some kind and you know
golf balls and just it's a lot of stuff
golf balls you know when you're there
for four years it's a long time and it's
a lot of stuff and they send it down
sent down by I believe it was sent down
by GSA the government now Trump's not
even it's such a it's such everything is
crazy because
the answer doesn't really make any sense
he's also not saying whether he packed
it and picked the things like that's the
Crux of the question
who packed this stuff up and decided
these are the documents you're taking
and he's talking about gear and golf
balls and you know the other thing just
to show you that secret
on the sidewalk
waiting for trucks to come in to take it
in other words it's not like this was
some Sinister plot they have pictures of
guys standing outside the box is
literally outside the sun is pouring
down and they're waiting for a truck
right and then they have pictures
putting them on the truck there's
nothing the sun is pouring down like
liquid secret about it it didn't have to
be anything secret and all the
classified but when you look at what
they've done and you look at even
something like this when you look at
what they're doing to our country
it's hard to believe yeah making a whoa
making a lot of sense there for sure
um if in case any of you are looking for
something to do apparently Charlie Kirk
and Candace Owens are doing a tour it's
free it's free to go the this is the
fall tour and they're going to be
speaking at the University of Delaware
the University of Texas at Austin
Michigan State North Dakota State
University of Missouri
Florida State University and the
University of North Carolina it's the
exposing critical racism tour and as you
can see it is really a party
it is really really really a party
so if anybody's interested in that and
um
yeah I mean I don't know that there's
much else to say about it here's Alex
Berenson the wrongest man in the world
on the pandemic he was on Joe Rogan and
he seems to think Biden wants him banned
from Twitter or something I've now been
publishing documents that show that the
White House wanted me banned and that is
the biggest part of all of this okay
that's where the story is going now that
people inside the White House this is
and this is this is Twitter employees
talking to each other about a meeting
that they had in April of 2021 before
Twitter had ever done anything to me
right where they said they said that the
White House said why is this guy still
allowed to tweet right and at that time
they were saying to each other these
Twitter employees we think he's fine we
don't think he's doing anything wrong
well you fast forward to July of 2021
just over a year ago and Joe Biden says
the vaccine anybody who debates the
vaccines if social media platforms allow
that they are quote unquote killing
people
and then less or barely a month
everybody's just focused on Alex
Berenson if you believe this Twitter
employees are all about Alex Barris of
Aaronson Biden's yell Biden's going
around the White House going Alex
Berenson must not be allowed to debate
vaccines on Twitter like that's totally
plausible guys after that four hours
after that I should say Twitter puts a
strike against me they begin the process
of de-platforming me six weeks later
they de-platform me so my position and
I'm gonna Sue I said I'm gonna sue the
White House and I'm gonna guys any day
now he's gonna Sue
they said that the one
uh my position is that those that there
are people inside the Biden
Administration who violated my rights as
an American citizen violated my first
amendment rights tried to get Twitter to
suppress me personally that's where this
is going
wow wow absolutely mind-blowing stuff
um here's diamond and silk I had my
colleague John sent this to me
apparently diamond and silk lost it on
their show I don't know
foreign
all right well anyway so that's going on
Obama
um and then here is Grant stinkfield
saying Satan has taken over the
Democratic Leadership I guess what
president Trump is up against right now
especially this Mar-A-Lago raid and the
people that orchestrated it
um this is satanic in nature and I don't
say that lightly that's a really he
wouldn't just call anything satanic
lightly he's really considered whether
it's appropriate to call this satanic I
do believe the people that are waging
this war against President Trump uh
really are evil to the court these are
not people that have what they believe
is their best intention look a guy like
Bernie Sanders I have respect a guy like
Bernie Sanders because I think he truly
believes that he's being well
intentioned he believes what he's
pushing I wildly disagree with him I
think everything he pushes is wrong but
at least he believes in what he's doing
when you look at the likes of Nancy
Pelosi and you look at the likes of job
and the people pulling their strings I'm
not convinced they believe that what
they're doing is best for the nation in
fact it's just the opposite I actually
believe they're doing this on purpose
they're going after president Trump on
purpose they talk about disenfranchising
voters with anyway I'm so bored with
stinkfield but he believes that when he
looks at Biden he sees Satan there
that's what that really that really
takes something huh
um Michael says via Super Chat David
sirkin we hear Trump mispronouncing
names and words I do have a whole
section on my soundboard that includes
that type of thing I've had more
investigations and Jesse James ability
that could a rhino named Mitt Romney Max
silicone we've endorsed JP right JD
Mandel no more Dropbox the drop boxes
and take a look at the oranges of the
investigation truth essential Kofi
and the combat infant trip and
Advising lawmakers if you care about Law
and Order
that's still one of my favorite law and
Auto uh man that is that is something
else
statistics coming out on one yep
Americans of all walks of life rose up
there it is and a classic also president
Donald J Trump
man that is something else and then I
know there's Trump mispronouncing Indian
names as well let me see if I have
because that is oh here it is
[Applause]
man that guy was out of his mind that is
really something else
uh Jason says look we all know about
Trump's gear it's all uppers half-eaten
McDoubles and classified documents
exactly and he eats all of them
uh that's all stuff that all stuff that
he's eating all right we are moments
away from President Joe Biden addressing
the nation to warn us as if we need
another warning about the threats to
democracy posed by the Maga movement I
want to say thank you to Desiree Delong
and Adam Gingrich for gifting to
subscriptions to to Lucky people at
joinpakman.com incredibly the list of
people waiting for a free membership
swelled like Donald Trump's head to 1100
people and we've worked that down into
the 800s thanks to some generous gifts
you can put your name on the list for a
free membership at davidpackman.com free
membership I if you don't want to wait
and my recommendation is get a
membership right now
you can go to joinpakman.com use the
coupon code indict we all know why the
coupon code is in Diet okay you go to
joinpakman.com right now and you can
sign up I want to say thanks to Heather
and Gary Egan who just got a membership
on my website and our new members 44. we
will run it all the way up to 100. also
over on Twitch I want to say thank you
to ASF klopp's blueberry babe and
standardized Genie three really great
people oh the Starbucks thing yeah let
me talk about the Starbucks thing so on
I'm not actually joking about this but
if you already are a member you would
know this because I told the story on
the bonus show oh the bonus show
that I had a 20-year streak
of not going to Starbucks it wasn't a
corporate protest I just think the
coffee is trash okay I think it's cop
thefti
kafifi whatever you want to say I think
it's terrible and I patronize local
coffee shops local coffee shops okay
a couple weeks ago I was in Montreal I
used to say Montreal and all of the
quebecois wrote to me and said David
with tears in their eyes they said David
sir please pronounce it correctly it's
Montreal I was coming back from Montreal
I had uh uh you know my daughter in the
car desperately needing a diaper change
and I needed to charge the car and so I
was restricted in where I was able to go
and I was tired I was tired because it
had just been a very very long night
okay so I was my options around the
charging station where I could walk
were
um man I don't even it was like
um like a Panera okay
and a Price Chopper or something like
that and a Starbucks so I said you know
what it's a matter of safety I must be
awake I don't want to endanger my family
with the driving the highway driving
plus my car basically drives itself so
there's very little to do on the highway
and I said I'm gonna have to go and get
a coffee at Starbucks
and I said I'm going in with an open
mind it's been 20 years it it could be
okay I mean it could be fine so I went
over and I ordered a small cappuccino
they were like oh that's called like a
grand Grande or so you know who the hell
knows venti venti uh tall I don't know
anyway and some people afterwards were
like well David that you've got it the
way you the things that are good at
Starbucks are XYZ things that are a
thousand calories right no I wanted a
coffee not a dessert people okay I
wanted a coffee so cappuccino is the
perfect test can you steam the milk and
is the espresso okay and
um it was absolute trash I mean it was
just it was absolutely horrifying first
of all they hand me the cup it's covered
in coffee the outside of the cup is
covered in coffee
if you're a barista and you want to be
taken seriously have the common decency
if you spill coffee all over the outside
of the cup at least slide it into
another cup if not make it over again
you know what I mean like like let's
have some respect here and then I taste
it and it's just garbage the milk was
completely scalded I know many of you
probably are aware of this
when in a cappuccino
this isn't like give me a hot black
coffee where you want the stuff at 210
degrees Fahrenheit in a cappuccino on my
espresso machine I'm selecting 142
degrees for the milk temperature
142. you know and I know I may not have
my machine very long we're doing a class
action lawsuit against all machines over
54 countries have now been taken by the
machines right so anyway to the extent
that I have my machine I'm doing 142
maybe 144 degrees on the milk if you go
above 160 it's scalded okay it was the
milk was completely scalded the the
espresso was it's such a dark roast it
would probably ruin my espresso machine
it's so dark and oily it was absolute
garbage I drank it because it was a
matter of safety ladies and gentlemen it
was a matter of safety but I took 20
years off from Starbucks I went back
it was garbage and I'm just not doing it
I'm just not doing it I'm going back to
my you know third wave cafes and
um light and medium roasts and properly
steamed milk that's and also it was not
even really foam they just like ripped
the crap out of it and it was too hot
and it was just terrible it was terrible
so anyway for all the people who were
saying David you give it another shot
it's good it's good it's good it was
terrible all right let's move on and
never speak of it again please I'm
hemorrhaging viewers due to this uh due
to this perspective all right I want to
say thank you to Steve Turner Steve
Turner just did a patriotic thing and
signed up for a membership on my website
joinpakman.com uh now I'm gonna preview
something for you guys again if you are
a member and you have access to the
bonus show oh the bonus show where you
want to make money but everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves is
bad you would already have seen this
interview today I interviewed a
republican so nuts he was unendorsed by
his own party let's look at a little bit
of this interview well today we're going
to be and with with with permission I'm
gonna play it back at 1.25 just so we
can cover a little bit more of it
speaking with Mike cargile Mike cargile
is running for congress in California's
35th congressional district uh I believe
Mike you're the only Congressional
candidate this cycle who it has been
unendorsed by the Republican party is
that is that a correct credential that
you have Yes actually I am the only
Congressional candidate in the nation
who's been unendorsed twice now by the
Republican party for being what they
consider too conservative so give me any
was there communication did they tell
you on what issues you're just too far
to the right
no actually they scrolled we a few weeks
ago they had an unendorsement meeting of
their board of directors yeah and they
said here you've got two minutes to talk
and I said talk about what what do you
want to talk about and they said well
watch this and they rolled four minutes
of memes off of Facebook that go all the
way back to 2018 and I knew where this
came from because this was how George
Soros had attacked me in the last cycle
oh Soros is going after you he has and
and so the Republican party is using the
Soros Playbook uh he came after me I'm
pretending like this guy's not
criminally insane with Media Matters and
axios last time would you say Soros has
infiltrated the Republican establishment
at this point yes wow yes so they uh
they came after me and tried to you know
remember back in 2020 this was the world
of BLM riots and things like that so of
course he had Unearthed a conversation a
private conversation I had had with a
friend of mine about the use that were
the prevalent use of the n-word in rap
music and I said that's all you know so
we're typing this out and I said that's
all they're doing right now is building
the songs around the n-word and I typed
the n-word out expressing you know my
concern because I'm not a word you would
ever use other than citing it of course
correct correct now that this guy
there's so many instances of this guy
using the n-word by the way if you
Google him but but you have when you're
having a conversation in messenger you
have to type it out right and so they
found this and said oh look he's a
racist he's using the n-word and that
was the narrative and the New York Times
picked it up LA Times Boston you know
everywhere suddenly because of the
environment at that time well that is so
Mike I don't want to let this slip
because this is mind-blowing George
Soros who at the time of I guess when
this happened was 90 I think he's 92 now
90 year old George Soros obtained a
private text communication that you had
with someone else bemoaning the use of
the n-word in rap music is that right
yes wow that is an incredible story
oh God they they take it and they go
look see white guy writes out the n-word
and he's a racist and then you know they
might just sort of cascade and that's
it's almost unbelievable to be perfectly
Frank I think many in my audience will
struggle to believe that well it's what
happened and it was what was
regurgitated by the California are you
guys struggling to believe it when your
Republican party a couple weeks ago well
as as further evidence and they they
said publicly in their meeting uh anyone
can can look this up because it's all
over the internet now what they did to
me but but they said how did this guy
make it through the primary we
unendorsed him in 2020 and here he is
again we're having to unendorse him
again
in the country what uh just as a gut
check we're doing this when we speak to
2022 candidates it's a weird question to
ask but I hope you'll indulge me who is
the real president of the United States
right now
well who's sitting in the white house
that's the that's you know that's Joe
Biden right was he there legitimately I
don't know let's find out I'm the I'm on
a lawsuit that's at the ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals right now our oral
arguments will begin September 23rd and
we're asking to forensically audit 13
counties in California California
lawsuit in the nation is it and I want
to get to the bottom of this question
because people go he's not legit he is
legit it was stolen it wasn't stolen
folks nobody knows well but hold on a
second Mike let's see if we can break
that down though because so nobody knows
we have we have results from California
right the results from California are
Biden got 11.1 million votes Trump got
six million votes overwhelming victory
for bite those are the results we have
in order to say we don't know we should
have some reason to question those
results what reason do you have to
question the results that make you say I
can't be confident that we have the real
numbers well David if you were an
Olympian and you ran a race and you got
the gold medal let's say you're like
Usain Bolt you ran this race you got the
gold medal what's the first thing they
do after you set that world record
they do a blood test okay and they they
check to see if you have performance
enhancing drugs in your system okay
that's an audit they do an audit of your
bloodstream why don't we do the same
thing with the greatest race in the
world which is the U.S presidential
election well I think one reason would
be just the voter registration numbers
in California are so lopsided towards
Democrats that it's very hard to believe
that there would be any real outcome
there other than Biden easily winning I
mean let me ask you a question what do
you suspect were the real results in
California
I don't know okay no but it's a cop-out
to say you don't know what reason do you
have to question the results thousands
and thousands of affidavits that have
been submitted to my coplaintiff under
you know the notarized and uh you know
the charge of perjury if you lie on this
the ballots were covered in performance
enhancing drugs that they saw things
that were not right conducted in a
myriad of places including the polling
places including ballot drop-off boxes
nobody knows and yet no one wants to
look and all I'm asking with my
copelander says let's open the hood and
let's actually see what occurred okay
when you look at the voter registration
numbers
even if there were tens of thousands or
even hundreds of thousands of these
instances right California only 24 of
registered voters are Republicans
there's just no way Trump could have won
well I'm not I'm not saying that I'm
saying that did you know this okay there
are there are 2.8 million more
registered voters in California than
there are citizens no that is absolutely
untrue I we've got the data to prove it
my co-oplaintiff is the election
Integrity project California okay and
they listen because I don't have I mean
we did I've not seen that I mean send it
to me send it to me you know every state
in which it has been claimed that there
are more voters than citizens it has
been it has been debunked and it seems
in California it wouldn't be even close
has any state done a forensic audit well
the states have done all sorts of
evaluations and recounts and audits but
then someone always hold on but Mike
hold on hold on hold on someone then
comes along and says that's not the type
of audit I meant
no they've done recounts nobody has done
an audience but in Arizona an audit was
done and it found Biden got even more
votes the the Arizona audit was not done
properly he doesn't like that audit he
means an audit what he means is an audit
that shows Trump one that's what they
mean by an audit what we're looking for
is this we have three things in our
complaint yeah here's the ballot I want
to look at the envelope and then let's
look at the machine okay they've had to
look at the end I do do some pillow
trolling in a moment I couldn't resist
the images of the the hard drives we
have the voter rolls and let's compare
all four of those all right well let's
do that we're not going to be able to do
it today so in the interest we can start
today because I know I mean you and I
won't be able to now listen I want to
ask you something there's this guy who
we my audience knows him as Mike pillow
he's the CEO of my pillow Mike Lindell
but as a shorthand we'll sometimes call
him Mike pillow or even just pillow
everybody knows who he is he is obsessed
with the machines and he actually wants
to sue every machine are you where are
you on the machines
well I think the machines need to be
looked at okay I think just like the
nest to Souza's movie with uh 2000 mules
the ballot drop-off boxes need to be
looking good
um one of the one of the areas in our
lawsuit is the article for section four
of the U.S Constitution it's called the
the guarantee clause and the federal
government is supposed to guarantee that
we are free from foreign Invasion but it
doesn't say how the foreign invasion is
conducted and right now we have no
safeguards in California election law to
say China can't submit 30 million
ballots and we have no way to safeguard
against it can you imagine this line of
reasoning when they under the guise of
covet have removed all the safeguards in
place but Mike do you have reason to
believe China submitted 30 million
ballots it's very easy to say I can't
prove to you that it wasn't done you
can't prove to me it wasn't done but do
you have reason to believe China
submitted 30 million ballots I've seen
no such evidence I I don't need the
evidence I have the Constitution which
says he just needs Hyperbole and
conjecture any law that allows China to
do this is unconstitution
because it allows for foreign Invasion
whether it's at The Ballot Box or the
shoreline how can China submit 30
million ballots when you have to be an
American citizen in order to even
register to vote how is that even
possible because you can do it through
the ballot boxes no verification needed
in California you can have same-day
voter registration you don't have to
vote you can literally walk in on
November 8th and say I've never voted in
my life before and I like about it right
but if you're walking in and voting that
then you're an American citizen who who
is registering to vote how is China
doing that they can do it at the they
can do it through the boxes the drop-off
boxes see they can't deny any ballot
they receive up until the close of
business November 8th right but then
they look at it and if it's not a
registered if it's not if it's not a
citizen then it's an invaluable how does
they know it's not a citizen there's no
checks in place you don't know they're
not even allowed to ask for ID they
don't know if you're a citizen a
non-citizen in California this is the
thing David Mike Mike there were 17
million votes in California okay just
just here out the number there were 17
million votes in California Biden got
11. Trump got six when you talk about
any one Ballot Box and you talk about
China and 30 million ballots and on and
on even if I grant you that every one of
your thousands of affidavits is bona
fide proof of some fraud right bona fide
proof when the popular when the voting
public is only 17 million people how on
Earth do you think that they're going to
be able to slip by this number of
fraudulent fake whatever votes and only
a few thousand people submit affidavits
it but it's impossible to believe that
well then would you join me in calling
for an audit of the system so I I see no
reason to audit this there's just the
numbers don't add up there's no reason
to audit it no if you won the gold medal
we would automatically audit the race
okay well there should be Olympic
Olympic 100 meter dash is not voting did
you have no I mean Mike that doesn't
make any sense it sounds silly it makes
total sense because any competition in
the United States if Tom Brady isn't
this crazy Brady uses an under inflated
football yeah we almost tear the country
apart why don't we do that for the
greatest competition in the land this
sounds so silly though Mike it sounds
silly I don't know that this is going to
win you the 35th District I'm not sure
well I'm not trying to to you know
please somebody I'm trying to say let's
get to the bottom of this issue so that
we can all be comfortable with U.S
elections once again most people are
comfortable that's the thing when you
pull people most people are comfortable
no that's not true what poll do you have
well the poll of my district and I can I
can show you that by the amount of
people who wait to go to the polling
locations because they don't trust
that's not a poem most people just vote
on Election Day that doesn't mean they
don't trust another system listen Mike
we don't have unlimited time there's a
really other important thing I want to
ask you about because I read this about
you do you believe that a satanic cabal
is in charge of the United States
I think there's a satanic cabal running
the world oh
yes all right let's pause there we will
pick up the interview I'll show you the
rest of the interview after Joe Biden's
speech okay because it this is this is
where it really gets nuts and I actually
say to him why are all the satanic
people you're mentioning black or Jewish
I actually say that to him in the
interview okay so we're going to get to
that a little bit later welcome
everybody we are standing by for
President Joe Biden I want to say thank
you to Bone Master Jay C missile and GW
Jump Man for their twitch Prime
subscriptions our friend s Perez just
gifted 21 twitch subscriptions s press
is the top gifter of subscriptions ever
on Twitch at
1061 if you can believe that
also thanks to shot X Thomas Heigl
and your billion as well as Chaya La
latte
regnera okay thank you to all of those
people and over on my website Adam Ellis
as well as Adam Bryant have signed up
for new memberships and then Lisa Rader
and Shamari Vazquez have gifted
memberships that puts us at 80. folks I
will make this plea to you only once
today we are an independent media
program we primarily depend on people
who get memberships on my website one of
the great benefits of being a member is
we do an extra show for you every day
called the bonus show I'm not kidding
Alex Jones has denounced the bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad I can think of No
Greater endorsement of what I am doing
than Alex Jones thinking it is terrible
man's a loser so my request to you is
get yourself a membership at
joinpakman.com we have the coupon code
indict which saves you big and if you
want to save even more you can use the
coupon code obamna Obama but you have to
spell it correctly incorrectly what I
mean by that is Obama o b a m n as in
Nancy a Obama
um and joinpakman.com is the place to do
that and I welcome folks support I will
also if we get to a hundred tonight be
live live live on Saturday with this
with the Donald Trump rally I can only
imagine with indictment pending that
Trump is going to be on fire on fire on
Saturday all right thanks to S Prez for
gifting another eight subscriptions as
well as Ace of trace and Nikki for
re-upping on Twitch Prime very much
appreciate that
super chat's coming in Mart says aside
from the Starbucks incident how was your
trip to Montreal did you get your fill
of patine I actually did not have
poutine on this trip I just I just
forgot quite frankly I forgot about
poutine which seems criminal but I had
lots of other great things including
Saint Viator bagels and some great great
meals and saw some great people I met up
with Canadian MP Anthony house father
one of the members of parliament of
Canada from the liberal party and we had
a great chat uh and it was just it was
just a great trip great trip David hope
you got to enjoy Montreal Bagels I did
as a New Yorker I can vouch for them
also did you hear about the stolen
Dominion machine sold on eBay just saw
dhoni cover I did not hear about that
I did not hear about that that sounds
Wild
David you're the man can you tell me
what building this speech is in front of
I believe this is Independence Hall is
that correct can anybody correct me on
that and tell me for sure
I believe it is Independence Hall
Yes No Maybe So I'm Googling it now
myself
yes it seems to be
uh Cody says donating me donating
because the Pacman show where he makes
money to sustain himself is good but
everyone else who wants to make money is
bad completely agree
completely and totally agree
big thank you to Abe baginski and
Christopher Brandon who also goes by
dark Brandon is what I've been told for
signing up on my website joinpakman.com
very much appreciate that Joe Biden
expected quite literally any moment here
I believe CNN also will be covering the
speech yes indeed we are standing by for
Joe Biden and I I do think it's going to
be very interesting to see how he takes
on remember the whole semi-fascism thing
um I think he's gonna double down on
that I don't believe that uh Joe Biden
is going to back away from that not even
for a second
you have to go to passe compose for
brunch in Montreal it's insanely good oh
interesting I've not heard of that place
uh let's see
Montreal
oh yeah this place looks good
they've got rural Poached Eggs they're
goose eggs I can't say I've ever eaten a
goose egg but it sounds very interesting
certainly uh something I would I would
consider that very strongly thanks to
Rosie Gomez for signing up at
joinpakman.com folks if we get to a
hundred we will have another stream
Saturday
uh the Trump rally do you have Pac-Man
approved Super Beta supplements I can
buy you know unfortunately I don't all I
can offer you is a membership and the
bonus show I don't I don't really have
anything like that that I can sell you
um some people are maybe happy about
that I don't know
uh
uh yeah
I'm in Philly wanted to go see dark
Brandon but I have too much planning for
the canvas I'm leading on Friday any
philadelphians want a canvas all right
uh well we don't know what you're
canvassing for but you can contact
Superman if you're looking to canvas on
Friday thanks to smoke and Hulk Logan
and Ian not eon
for the twitch Prime subscriptions
putting us at 95 we are moments away
from President Joe Biden after the the
speech we will get back to my interview
with Mike cargile
where we get to the satanic portion of
the speech which I think is going to be
nuts absolutely nuts thank you to Carl
McKay for signing up on my website and
thanks to Martin fillian for gifting a
subscription as well as Kevin Combs that
puts us at 98
98 and we are getting dangerously close
Beth Graham has gifted a subscription
and puts us at 99 quite literally at the
stroke of the start of the speech Let's
listen
Obama
and indeed Alyssa Fink is new member
number 100 today Alyssa thank you so
much for your support let's listen to
the president expect it to call out Maga
threats to democracy
whoa
wow
[Music]
my fellow Americans oh God the voice not
the voice I have a seat
tell you
I speak to you tonight from sacred
ground in America
Independence Hall in Philadelphia
Pennsylvania
this is where America made its
Declaration of Independence to the world
more than two centuries ago and with an
idea
unique among nations
that in America
we're all created equal
this is where the United States
Constitution was written and debated
this is where we set in motion
the most
extraordinary experiment of
self-government the world has ever known
with three simple words
we the people we the people
these two documents and the idea is they
embody
equality and democracy
are the rock upon which this nation is
built
for how we became the greatest nation on
Earth
there why
for more than two centuries America has
been a beacon to the world
but as I stand here tonight
equality and democracy are under assault
we do ourselves no favor to pretend
otherwise true so tonight
I've come to this place where it all
began
to speak as plainly as I can
to the nation the right Wingers are
going to claim that this is satanic what
would the dark and red and oh my God
it's just wait until what you see
tomorrow on right-wing media
and about the incredible future the lies
in front of us if only we choose it
must never forget
We the People
are the true Heirs of the American
experiment
that began more than two centuries ago
We the People
are burning inside of each of us
the flame of Liberty
that was lit here at Independence Hall
dark Brandon a flame
and led our way through abolition the
Civil War suffrage
a Great Depression world wars Civil
Rights
that sacred flame still Burns
now in our time
as we build an America it is more
prosperous
free and just
that is the work of my presidency
a mission
I believe in with my whole soul
but first
we must be honest with each other
and with ourselves
too much of what's happening in our
country today is not normal correct
Donald Trump and the Maggie Republicans
represented extremism that threatens the
very foundations of our Republic
clear
very clear up front
not every Republican not even the
majority Republicans are maggot
Republicans
not every Republican Embraces their
extreme ideology
I know
because I've been able to work with
these mainstream Republicans
but there's no question
that the Republican party today is
dominated driven and intimidated
by Donald Trump and the Maggie
Republicans oh yeah and that is a threat
to this country
these are hard things
but I'm an American president
not a president of red America blue
America
but of all America
and I believe it's my duty my duty to
love with you to tell the truth no
matter how difficult
no matter how painful
and here in my view is what is true
Maggie Republicans do not respect the
Constitution
they do not believe in the rule of law
they do not recognize the will of the
people
they refuse to accept the results of a
free election true and they're working
right now as I speak in state after
state
to give power to decide elections in
America to partisans and cronies the
lunatics empowering election deniers to
undermine democracy itself
Maga forces are determined to take this
country backwards
backwards to an America
where there is no right to choose
no right to privacy
no right to contraception no right to
marry who you love folks
they promote authoritarian leaders and
they fan the Flames of political
violence
that are a threat to our personal rights
to the pursuit of Justice
to the rule of law to the very soul of
this country
they look at the mob the storm the
United States capital on January 6th
brutally attacking law enforcement
not as insurrectionist
who placed a dagger at the throat of our
democracy but they're looking as
Patriots
and they see their mag of failure to
stop a peaceful transfer of power
after the 2020 election
as preparation for the 2022 and 2024
elections
they're tried everything last time to
nullify the votes of 81 million people a
lot of screaming in the background first
time
they're determined to succeed in
thwarting
the
people
that's why
why respect to conservatives like
federal circuit court judge Michael
ludding
has called Trump an extreme maggot
Republicans quote a clear and present
danger to our democracy
but while the threat to American
democracy is real
I want to say as clearly as we can
we are not powerless
in the face of these threats
we are not bystanders in this ongoing
attack on democracy
there are far more Americans
far more Americans
remember every from every background of
belief
to reject the extreme mag ideology
than those that accept it
and folks
is within our power it's in our hands
yours and mine
to stop the assault on American
democracy
I believe America is at an inflection
point
one of those moments
that determine the shape of everything
that's to come after
and now America must choose
to move forward
or to move backwards
to build a future or obsess about the
past
to be a nation of Hope and unity and
optimism
or a nation of fear
Division and of Darkness
Maggie Republicans have made their
choice
they Embrace anger
they thrive on chaos
they live not in the light of truth but
in the shadow of Lies
but together
we can choose a different path
we can choose a better path
forward to the future
a future a possibility a future to build
and dream and Hope
and we're on that path moving ahead
I know this nation
I know you the American people
I know your courage
I know your hearts
and I know our history
this is a nation that honors our
constitution we do not reject it
this is a nation that believes in the
rule of law
we do not repudiate it well some of us
believe in it this is a nation that
respects free and fair elections we
honor the will of the people we do not
deny it
and this is a nation
that rejects violence as a political
tool some of us do do not encourage
violence Lindsay does we are still on
America that believes in honesty and
decency
and respect for others teachers of
Liberty justice for all hope
possibilities we are still at our core a
democracy
and yet
history tells us
the blind loyalty to a single leader
and a willingness to engage in political
violence is fatal to democracy
for a long time
we've told ourselves that American
democracy is guaranteed
but it's not
we have to defend it
protect it stand up for it each and
every one of us
that's why tonight
I'm asking our nation to come together
unite behind the single purpose of
defending our democracy regardless of
your ideology please
we're all called by Duty and conscience
to confront extremists who put their own
pursuit of power Above All Else
Democrats Independents mainstream
Republicans
we must be stronger more determined and
more committed to saving American
democracy
and Maggie Republicans are just to
destroying American democracy
We the People
will not let anyone or anything tear us
apart
today
there are dangers around us
we cannot allow to prevail
we hear you've heard it
more and more talk about violence
as an acceptable political tool too much
in this country
it's not
it can never be an acceptable tool
so I want to say this plain and simple
there is no place
for political violence in America period
none ever
[Applause]
you saw law enforcement brutally
attacked on January 6th
we've seen election officials poll
workers many of them volunteers of both
parties subject to intimidation and
death threats
and can you believe it FBI agents
just doing their job as directed facing
threats
to their own lives from their own fellow
citizens that's MaGa on top of that
there are public figures today yesterday
and the day before predicting and all
the calling for Mass violence and riding
in the streets
this is inflammatory
dangerous it's against the rule of law
and we the people must say this is not
Who We Are
ladies and gentlemen
we can't be pro-ex Pro X pro
insurrectionist
and pro-american they're incompatible
we can't allow violence to be normalized
in this country it's wrong
we each have to reject political
violence with with all the moral Clarity
and conviction this nation can muster
now
we can't let the Integrity of our
elections be undermined for that is a
path to chaos
look I know polish policies can be
fierce and mean and nasty in America I
get it
I believe in the give and take of
politics and disagreement and debate and
dissent
we're a big complicated country
but democracy endures only if We the
People respect the guard rails of the
Republic only if
We the People accept the results of free
and fair elections only if
We the People
see politics
not as Total War but mediation of our
differences
democracy cannot survive
when one side believes there are only
two outcomes to an election
either they win
or they were cheated
and that's where the Maggie Republicans
are today yep
thank you
they don't understand what every
patriotic America knows
you can't love your country only when
you win
it's fundamental
American democracy only works
only if we choose to respect the rule of
law and the institutions that were set
up in this chamber behind me
only if
we respect our legitimate political
differences
I will not Stand By and Watch I will not
the will of the American people be
overturned by wild conspiracy theories
and baseless evidence-free claims of
fraud I will not Stand By and Watch
elections in this country stolen by
people who simply refuse to accept that
they lost
thank you
I will not stand by and watch the most
fundamental freedom in this country the
freedom to vote and have your vote
counted
and be taken from you and the American
people
look
as your president I will defend our
democracy with every fiber of my being
and I'm asking every American to join me
[Applause]
throughout our history
America's often made the greatest
progress
coming out of some of our darkest
moments like you're hearing to that
bullhorn another protester I believe we
can and must do that again
and we are
Maggie Republicans look at America and
see Carnage and darkness and despair
they spread fear and lies
lies toll for profit and Power
but I see a different America
an America with an unlimited future
an American is about to take off
I hope you see it as well just look
around
I believe we could lift America from the
depths of covert so we passed the
largest economic recovery package since
Franklin Delano Roosevelt and today
America's economy is faster stronger
than any other Advanced nation in the
world we have more to go
I believe we could build a better
America
so we passed the biggest infrastructure
investment since president Dwight D
Eisenhower and we've now embarked on a
decade of rebuilding the nation's roads
Bridges highways ports water system
high-speed internet railroads
I believe we can make America safer so
we passed the most significant gun
safety law since President Clinton
I believe
[Applause]
we could go from being the highest cost
of prescriptions in the world to making
prescription drugs and health care more
affordable so we passed the most
significant Health Care reform since
President Obama signed the Affordable
Care Act
Obama
and I believe to create
we could create a clean energy future
and save the planet
so we passed the most important climate
initiative ever ever ever
[Applause]
the cynics and the critics
tell us nothing can get done but they're
wrong
there is not a single thing America
cannot do not a single thing beyond our
capacity if we do it together
it's never easy
but we're proving that America no matter
how long the road progress does come
[Applause]
look
I know the last year a few years have
been tough
but today
covert no longer controls Our Lives
more Americans are working than ever
businesses are growing our schools are
open
millions of Americans have been lifted
out of poverty millions of veterans once
exposed to toxic burn pits will now get
what they deserve for their families in
the comparison compensation
American manufacturers come alive across
the Heartland and the future will be
made in America
no matter what the White supremacists
and the extremists say
I made a bet on you the American people
and that bet is paying off proving that
from Darkness the darkness of
Charlottesville of covet of gun violence
of insurrection we can see the light
light is now visible
light that will guide us forward
not only in words but in actions actions
for you for your children for your
grandchildren for America
Even In This Moment with all the
challenge we face
I give you my word as abide and I've
never been more optimistic about
America's future not because it may be
because of who you are
going to end cancer as we know it mark
my words
we're going to create millions of new
jobs in the clean energy economy we're
going to think big we're going to make
the 21st century another American
Century because the world needs us to
that's where we need to focus our energy
not in the past
not on divisive culture wars
not on the politics of grievance
but on the future we can build together
the Maggie Republicans believe that for
them to succeed everyone else has to
fail
they believe America is not like I
believe about America I believe America
is big enough for all of us to succeed
and that is the nation we're building
the nation where no one is Left Behind
I ran for president because I believe
we're in a battle for the soul of this
nation
I still believe that to be true
I believe the soul is the breath the
life and the essence of Who We Are
the soul is what makes us us
the soul of America is defined by the
sacred proposition that all are created
equal in the image of God
that all are entitled to be treated with
decency dignity and respect that all
deserve justice and a shot at lives of
prosperity and consequence
and that democracy democracy must be
defended for democracy makes all these
things possible
folks
and it's up to us
democracy begins and will be preserved
and we the people's habits of the heart
in our character
optimism that is tested yet endures
courage that digs deep when we need it
empathy that fuels democracy yeah
there's someone screaming F Joe Biden
and they've been doing it for like 10
minutes fellow Americans
look
our democracy is perfect
it always has been
I was standing those folks you hear on
the other side there
they're entitled to be outrageous
this is a democracy
but history and Common Sense
[Laughter]
oh man
[Applause]
good manners is nothing they've ever
suffered from what's history and Common
Sense tell us an opportunity liberty and
justice for all are most likely to come
to pass in a democracy
we have never fully realized the
aspirations of our founding
but every generation has opened those
doors a little bit wider to include more
people have been excluded before
my fellow Americans
America is an idea
the most powerful idea in the history of
the world
and the Beast in the hearts of the
people of this country
it beats in all our hearts it unites
America
it is the American creed
the idea that America guarantees that
everyone be treated with dignity
it gives hate no Safe Harbor
it installs in everyone the belief that
no matter where you start in life
there's nothing you can't achieve that's
who we are
that's what we stand for
that's what we believe
and that's precisely what we're doing
opening doors
creating possibilities
focusing on the future
and we're only just beginning
[Applause]
our task is to make our nation free and
fair
Justin strong Noble and whole and this
work is the work of democracy the work
of this generation it is the work of our
time for all time
we can't afford to have leave anyone on
the sidelines we need everyone to do
their part so speak up speak out get
engaged vote vote vote wow
and if we do our duty
if we do our duty in 2022 and Beyond
then age is still to come we'll say we
all of us here we kept the faith we
preserve democracy
we heeded our worst we
we heed and not our worst instincts but
our better angels we we proved that for
all its imperfections America is still
the beacon to the world
an ideal to be realized a promise to be
kept there's nothing more important
nothing more sacred
nothing more America
that's our soul
that's who we truly are
and that's a must we must always be
have no doubt none
that this is who we will be
and that will come together as a nation
that will secure our democracy
that for the next 200 years
will have what we had the past 200 years
the greatest nation on the face of the
Earth we just need to remember who we
are we are the United States of America
the United States of America
and may God protect our nation and may
God protect all those who stand watch
over our democracy God bless you all
democracy thank you
foreign
wow
[Music]
well dark Brandon rising of speech this
was designed to be your speech of
rhetoric this was not a policy speech
and many of you identifying that a
couple of different thoughts
first and foremost
making a lot of very accurate assessment
assessments of the decline of the
Republican Party
saying Donald Trump and his followers
represent okay
um yeah uh make making clear
how pathetic the right has become also
to some degree I saw a super chat from
Chris pointing this out maybe something
to prepare the nation for the indictment
of a former president I I don't think
that that's a crazy assessment when you
say listen
at some point there are certain things
that can't ever be ignored in the United
States
actual Law and Order you know not
whatever version of it Trump believes in
if you care about
right law and auto
um and maybe there is something in there
about preparing the country
for the indictment
of Donald Trump which would be quite a
scene quite a scene folks I promised you
the rest of my completely insane
interview with lunatic Republican Mike
cargile here's where we get into the
demonic stuff okay let's take a listen
and and when you say that like Davos and
the world economic forum who are some of
the satanic individuals
well you've seen a few of them already
they're they're they're not hiding it
you look at any profile high profile uh
rap artist uh you you know from the
Clinton Camp uh I believe Barack Obama
has been involved in some of it but you
look at that Soros is you look at the
Rockefeller types
um but then but then but Mike let's
really I want because sometimes people
are so vague Rockefeller type so I mean
let me just ask you is George Soros
demonically or satanically possessed I
don't know you don't know is Barack
Obama I don't know but you just listed
both of them have you ever asked them no
I've not spoken I've never asked them
but who am I right but what I'm saying
is I can only look at their actions and
do you believe that their actions are
evidence of satanic possession I don't
know but then why are you bringing their
names up because they're trying to
destroy Humanity okay who are the
Rockefeller types you mentioned
well you've seen him I'm not going to
get into to name dropping right now I'll
we'll deal with that later on who will
deal with it though it seems we would
want to know if you have the list I want
to know who these people are well if you
would get me the the uh Jeffrey Epstein
Glenn Maxwell list I could probably
point to a lot of them Mike I gotta ask
you a serious question here and I hope
you don't take offense are most of these
satanically possessed people either
black or Jewish because you're naming a
lot of black and Jewish people
I don't know their ethnicity you don't
know Obama's ethnicity well I is he
I don't know what he claims to be one
thing and he's but he's also playing uh
claimed publicly to be another thing
what do you mean well is he a U.S
citizen is he an African citizen is he
you know you know this goes back to the
whole you know birth certificate
argument oh my God I don't have a an
opinion on it I just know that this man
has has presented himself to be one way
and then his actions were entirely
another way he's been the most divisive
uh hate-filled President we probably had
ever had until Joe Biden which is really
Joe you know Obama 3.0 wow so you don't
know what what about Soros and Epstein
did you know that they're they're Jewish
I I don't care you know I don't care I
don't care what they are I'm judging
them by their actions more the content
of the character than the color of the
Skin So it seems a very superficial
argument to bring in can satanic
possession be cured
well if you remove the possessor I guess
so yeah how is that done though well
biblically it would be through an
exorcism or something of that nature wow
that sounds extremely serious
well are you demonically possessed not
that I'm aware of do I seem it to you no
okay I'm just saying it sounds like an
exorcism is very serious well I would
say that anyone who's bent on destroying
the human race yeah is probably in
League with the one that you would say
is the enemy of the human race and that
would be Satan himself well this is
bumming me out Mike I'm not gonna lie
this is a sad Outlook it's it's making
me uh sad about about Humanity but look
what just occurred David yeah we got
assaulted by a virus and then a vaccine
we were misled by we've got a green new
deal that's going to destroy and
collapse the U.S economy and that's just
the U.S look at what's going on in
Europe look what's going on in Asia it's
a concerted effort to thin the world of
humans dear God and then now on the
other end of that what's the goal why
thin the world of humans who benefits
well if you see people like you and I
yeah in God's image as your enemy well
then then you know that's a victory for
you you just get rid of the of the bad
people essentially and enough to have
sort of an army of slaves which is if
you take communism at its truest form
here's where it got really crazy that's
just a small group of people controlling
a very large group of people through
fear and dependency so we're looking at
a world of slaves that's being run by a
few people and they're okay they seem to
be okay with slavery as long as they get
to be the new Masters and that's where
your your color component comes in
because it's really not color dependent
it's who gets to play the master this
time around and we have I believe more
slaves now in the United States because
of our open Southern border and our
ports of Entry being wide open than
we've ever had and my opponent is one of
the chief wow Chief uh you know
supporters of the wide open border and I
believe is responsible for a lot of the
human trafficking that has come out of
particularly Guatemala but well Mike
listen I have not seen evidence of that
I will investigate it I have to say in
total honesty some of this stuff is
pretty out there even for the Republican
party so I sort of of understand the
unendorsement this is this is some
pretty out there stuff that you're
you're saying but just saying it's out
there doesn't mean it's not true it just
means you haven't come to terms with it
that's absolutely correct that's
absolutely correct and I think we would
all benefit if we would all call for
three things and that's that they would
release the Jeffrey Epstein tapes okay
and they would release the Glenn Maxwell
list you know how do you how do you get
charged I want to see that list sure I
know with human trafficking but but
there's no perpetrators we're the you
know you've got the victims but you
don't have the perps and then just join
me in calling for an audit of the
election system so we can put the issue
to bed if Joe Biden was fairly elected I
would be the first guy to say okay now
we've got our our marching orders let's
fight against it but if we don't if
we're not going to look under the hood
and see what happened yeah then we're
we're supporting cheating well Mike
cargile you've really said it all we are
going to be very closely watching that
race in the 35th congressional district
and I can't thank you enough for really
giving our audience uh a lot to think
about a lot to chew on for sure
appreciate your time thanks for having
me on David anytime I'm a I'm an open
book and if you want to talk about
anything I think that's the greatest
problem right now in the United States
is where everyone's yelling at each
other we must talk we must talk we must
talk and we can disagree but we need to
do so with civil discourse uh wow so
that was it guys um pretty pretty wacky
stuff not gonna lie
um and we'll you know it'll be on
YouTube it's gonna be clipped and all of
that different stuff thanks to everybody
coming in from tyt raiding us on Twitch
we were just looking at uh some uh
really really crazy interview after the
uh after the Joe Biden speech of those
asking if Donald Trump is posting
uncontrollably untruth Central he is not
as of right now so that is going to be
the end of coverage today I will be back
with everybody tonight we had dark
Brandon rising and then on Saturday
night we will have
um Donald Trump and we will hear from
him all right everybody thank you for
joining me see you very soon make sure
to follow on Twitch make sure to like on
Facebook make sure to subscribe on
YouTube to get notified of future
streams Pacman out
thank you